bienvenue au test de la version bêta
vous êtes l'organisateur non un
participant comme toi enfilez vos
combinaisons de combat cent mille
dollars de récompenses aux joueurs qui
termine avec le meilleur score
récupérez votre équipement c'est le
paradis des gamers
il commencera à tanger au sein du cac
3,2
[Musique]
vous avez déjà vu un truc pareil
c'est hallucinant
madame garde à vous le building a été
pris d'assaut par des terroristes
votre mission sera de les éliminer
si vous êtes touché vous perdez votre
armure on dirait une téléréalité charger
vos armes égales
tu as vu ce que j ai mis à à
mais aux dernières
pascoe
c'est super réalisme
[Musique]
ces casques ne nous protège pas
ils nous tuent
si on reste là on va crever
c'est pas un jeu
c'est plus le jeu